but first the real extremists
that's the focus of tonight's angle
today joe biden made it official mr
unity
will heal the wounds of a divided
america by using the power of the entire
federal government
to harass and investigate his political
adversaries
from our bloated intel agencies to the
doj and fbi
he and kamala will spy on americans they
don't trust and they don't much like
the department of homeland insecurity
sent out a scary-looking bulletin today
which read
information suggests that some
ideologically motivated violent
extremists with objections to the
exercise of governmental authority and
the presidential transition
as well as other perceived grievances
fueled by
false narratives could continue to
mobilize to incite
or commit violence now pay close
attention to that language
objections to governmental authority hmm
other perceived grievances
false narratives could mobilize
could commit violence sounds obscenely
vague and hypothetical right and then
when you read the accompanying press
release
dhs admits the truth they got nothing
dhs does not have any information to
indicate a specific
credible plot but once again it
ominously cites the possibility
that they remain concerned due to
grievances ideological causes
and false narratives now this isn't the
first time democrats have tried to
justify what would ultimately be an
attempt to roll back your civil
liberties
remember back in 2009 obama's dhs
secretary janet napolitano
warned about radicalized returning
veterans
and right-wing extremism in general
which she defined as
mainly anti-government it may include
groups and individuals that are
dedicated to
a single issue such as opposition to
abortion
or immigration now while the biden
bulletin
does make a vague reference to blm and
antifa but without naming them
it specifically lumps anti-lockdown
protesters into the same category as the
capitol rioters
whom the fbi has apparently put at the
top of their most wanted list
the enormity of this investigation is is
going to take a lot of work and a lot of
effort it's not going to be solved
within the coming months this is going
to be a long-term investigation the
brutality
the american people watched with shock
and disbelief on the 6th
will not be tolerated by the fbi the men
and women of the fbi will leave no stone
unturned
in this investigation well we want all
the criminals locked up
period but by the way that u.s attorney
interesting to note is the same one who
was more than happy to drop charges
against dozens of blm and antifa riders
over the summer huh
this just like keeping thousands of
national guard troops in washington
until the spring is a
choreographed setup piece to justify the
left's campaign
to intimidate punish and silence
ultimately their political opponents
now this effort it's not just immoral
it's illegal it's an american
and in court in practice it should be
declared unconstitutional
democrats are making a grave error here
republicans are going to eventually get
back into power and when they do they'll
leave no stone unturned to investigate
all of this and then the tables are
going to be turned on the agencies
and the individuals that ended up
profiling
and tracking innocent americans but
until
then or until the courts step in they're
going to try to scare you
into silent submission watch those
emails you're sending
if you're a vet who attends an
anti-lockdown protest
if you've done i don't know sidewalk
counseling at abortion centers if you
fly a thin blue line flag or if you
attended a trump rally
or maybe post it on facebook against
mail-in ballots
then you could be seen as a potential
domestic
terrorist who could be incited to
violence
or commit violence similar to what we
saw on january 6th
let's be clear here these cheap efforts
are so transparent
about it and intimidation they're not
going to work
and it's certainly not going to deter us
from fighting for what we know to be
true
as the declaration of independence makes
clear our rights
are inalienable our freedom comes from
god
and we're never going to get up give it
up to satisfy biden harris or the media
pals
conservatives and of course president
trump have repeatedly
and properly condemned all violence no
matter who's committing it
in fact we've urged the biden folks to
work with us on a whole bunch of issues
and aoc's cabal of radicals too why not
to work
with the populace on issues where we can
find common ground everything from china
trade to breaking up big tech
there's a lot we could do together but
instead they've decided
throw that out the window and go
scorched earth and spread
lies about tens of millions of innocent
americans
if they think that that's the way to
stop populism
by attempting to criminalize it oh boy
they are sorely mistaken
because today's announcements merely
confirmed that trump was right all along
washington's a swamp and it's run by
shadowy figures
who work on amassing power for
themselves
rewarding their friends and robbing the
working class blind
i guess that's what they meant when they
said that joe biden would get back to
regular order if he were elected that's
their regular order
the more that washington's elites prove
populist criticisms
to be correct the more pushback they'll
see
they should have learned that lesson in
2016 but they may have to learn it again
in 2024. again let there be no confusion
here our populist movement is loyal to
this country
and its political system we don't have
any desire to engage in violence or to
undermine our system of government
but we're not going to be silenced the
american people stood up to
the nazis we stood up to the soviet
union we came so far
we we addressed past wrongs
we're not going to back down to joe
biden and kamala harris for goodness
sakes
and that's the angle